I hate Asians I'm a hateful eight I hate
age I like I hate Asians I hate Johnny
Dang I don't eat Chinese food only time
I ever wanted some Chinese [__] was it a
bath house some Chinese slave I wouldn't
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I hate
Chinese people
trying to make I hate Chinese people I
think Chinese stores should be robbed I
think Chinese women should be
brutally by big boy or hung black man
all right should I get well
that hate Chinese women
China Mac I think Chinese babies should
be [__] in building uses alligator bait
I don't care how many times you hear
that is wild but let's keep playing I
think Chinese baby should be killed and
sodomized and use this alligator bait so
I looked into this guy this guy um I've
actually lost like two three interviews
after seeing some other stuff come like
what is what am I watching and
surprisingly enough on a lot of aspects
he's quite insightful he's well read in
watching some of that stuff I guess the
analogy that this guy was trying to make
when talks about alligator bait or
alligator or whatever
what's he used to do to science back in
the day okay and so he was making
assemblies to that kind of stuff not
even when you take into that whole
context this is some wild [__] to see on
the internet about any group and I think
I know those black folks will defend
this kind of stuff because they have a
very Like Us Versus their mentality
which to be fair if anyone's being
honest it's like minority communities
don't really get along with that well in
the states like people like wow well
it's like you know these groups in
America like they just don't like each
other no they're very secret game
um especially depending on what city
you're in it can be even more Amplified
to the point where you can't even walk
into certain areas if you're a different
color so
what do I think I mean what is it to
really think about something like this
this man is talking about sodomizing
children it's on camera
oh it's a troll it's a trout listen
y'all can't do this whole like I'm a
comedian thing when there's like no
punchline where's the [__] setup can
anyone tell me oh it's a character it's
a character sure it is sure it is it's
hard for me to say it's a character when
you come to find out that [__]
has done some similar [__] behind closed
doors that's the problem that's the
problem
when he admits to a certain crimes
sometimes he's being serious and other
times it's just a joke it's like what
what am I listening to you can't be as a
joke all the time oh that's what rappers
try to do oh it's art it's art meanwhile
you snitch on who the body was when you
did it where you did it and the police
find it why would they think it's a joke
you get me that's something
Beyond even just itself snitching it's
like we need to stop pretending like
some of these people who are saying this
stuff online are all doing these under
the guise of jokes we're all doing these
under the guys or whatever it's like I
said if they got them skeletons behind
closed doors sometimes it's okay to look
a little bit deeper and say them words
is not just jokes and they didn't sound
like a joke to me I don't even know how
anybody can look at this stuff and say
this is humorous
don't think about it too long but think
about it honestly like just just just
take a second irrespective of whatever
history there is or whatever think about
grown men today wishing
on children yes
um
like I don't know it's just when you you
like there's a certain element of like
self-preservation and I wanted to
different but I don't understand you're
talking about sizing children it's like
what are you trying to say in that joke
like when you do a joke there's an
actual process of doing a joke
it's not just saying stuff and wild
stuff in order to have a reaction no
that's not what a joke is there is a
process there's a way to do a joke there
is a recipe to do that joke okay set up
premise punch there's some key word
there's no setup there's no premise
there's no punch you're just saying
sentences there's a difference between
saying sentences and doing actual comedy
a lot of people out there it's not be
it's not everybody that made people
laugh that are comedians okay some of
y'all are clowns and I don't even know
what the hell that is that's gonna make
you laugh about this there's no setup
there's no premise there's no punch
yes you can laugh about everything but
there's a way to do it yeah people do
hide themselves behind the whole thing
about yeah it's a joke it's a joke it's
a character it's a prank it's a
character it turns out the thing he was
joking about is the very thing you did
you're being very wild right now even
even a prank thing yo it's a prank bro
why are you mad it's a prank like I'm
not supposed to be mad at pranks I'll do
the same thing I'll be honest with you I
don't hear white folks online saying
half is crazy [__] about black folks or
any other group that this band has said
about they can't I have never heard
I've heard some foul stuff from race
I've never heard anything even similar
to that
children how long do you want to go back
in the past to be able to justify the
[__] up [__] you're saying and doing
today what I've seen that video is that
all that was said because he hates one
dude
that happens to be of Asian descent okay
I question you
whenever you want to go at somebody but
you're going to go into foul [__] like
that that has nothing to do with the the
what the hell a person said I'm like nah
you're not the one
there's so many things that you could
have said about what he did and what you
don't like about what he did but that's
you're gonna install the whole thing
it's like I remember back in the days
when I was in elementary school or high
school and then you started arguing with
a boy person and the minute they didn't
have anything to say well you're in
came out really quick you want you know
what kills me like a lot of people are
caping and like defending this dude or
whatever he says meanwhile they had a
lot to say about just partly things and
like the minimal stuff that she did
don't get me wrong what she did no but
it's not even comparable if perlet said
half as many things about black folks as
this dude said about Asians they would
lose their goddamn [__] minds they
lost their goddamn [__] minds over
like over the innate of what she what he
said yeah so so this is the thing with
me with people it's like you guys are
willing to defend black men who do the
most disgusting and say the most foul
things because they're directed at other
groups okay well don't expect a lot of
sympathy from people when it comes to
ending your plot or any of your issues
if you just want to blindly defend each
other you're going to lose a lot of
folks you're gonna get the platform
you're gonna lose these things and of
course like no other group literally
nobody else of any shade of any color
can be created on this platform and say
the things he said so if he loses don't
be like oh my God the system The Matrix
no stupid that's you I know maybe he
doesn't care like there's a lot of
people who can make a living and do well
offline news okay that's fine I just
don't want to hear nobody crying to me
afterwards and complaining about like
this is unfair treatment like no you had
this [__] coming I'm kind of glad you
gone because this is some stupid [__]
you're saying yeah he's gotten away
so what wouldn't you like to do it uh
they said they calling you
so
yeah so what so what
we give the damn only white women so
what I got away with
who cares I don't I don't give a [__]
not one [__] [__] will I reap
again
I don't know
some hoes like to be ripped
I think sometimes black people
especially do an extreme poor job of
choosing people that they want to defend
in terms of their behavior yeah
you know because then it's like oh he
was such a good person [__]
murder 10 people he's such a good person
you're proud of what did R Kelly do free
R Kelly it's like what like they'll just
defend anybody who does some of the most
foul shits it's like y'all get rid of
the trash these people are hurting your
neighbors hurting the people in your
communities hurting the image of the
communities and y'all want to go out of
your way to make this [__] worse by
defending those people it's like I don't
know they did some [__] up [__] send
them to jail whether it's white people
whatever they talk about doing what to
Children
what are we even argue about yeah